. Let's go next to I guess this is is this
Ron from Los Angeles.
Or is this a Ron from Los Angeles, is it Aaron
from Los Angeles?
It might not matter because I think this person's
self muted and they're not around last chance
for Ron a Ron or just Erin from Los Angeles.
All right, they're gone.
That's too bad.
Let's go next to, um, let's go to Enock from
Pittsburgh.
You're on the air.
Hello.
Hi.
First of all, thank you for having me.
Pleasure.
So I just have a question about the Congress
vote that's coming up.
And I believe it's January 6th.
Yes.
So this is partially of my ignorance because
I'm still a little bit new to the politics
and how all of this work.
I'm honestly just learning about the Congress
vote to certify the Electoral College.
And I know it has been reported that several
senators and congressmen were planning to
vote against the Electoral College votes.
And I'm just wondering if you think that it's
still possible for Trump and his supporters
and within the Congress to try to steal the
election by voting against the Electoral College
results?
No, I don't think so.
Back in the year, remember that the role of
the vice president is simply to count the
votes, not to decide whether votes are valid
or anything like that.
So I do expect that there will be Republican
members of the House and maybe even the Senate
who, when certain votes are counted, will
stand up and present an objection.
Democrats tried this in the year 2000 when
the entire presidential election between Al
Gore and George W. Bush depended on Florida.
Democrats stood up and objected to the counting
of the Florida electoral votes, and they were
able to do nothing to stop it.
In this case, it doesn't even come down to
one state.
It comes down to multiple states.
So I expect objections.
I don't expect them to have any impact.
OK, thank you so much.
Yeah, I was just asking because I guess the
way I understood it was if they vote against
those votes, that I guess they need to vote
again.
But I guess that was my understanding of the
topic.
Yeah, I don't think I don't think it's going
to happen.
I appreciate the call.
Thank you very much.
I don't I don't expect that to happen, but
we'll be covering it live on January 6th,
that's for sure.
All right.
I'm sorry I wasn't able to talk to more folks
today, but we will take calls again in 2020.
One quick break.
Some audience questions coming up after this
short break.
The David Pakman Show and David Pakman Dotcom.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.